there christopher tell us a little bit
about this game and some of the others
so far in the event
yeah i'm
pretty happy with how my game went
yesterday was rough
i
lost a winning position but
how do you very happy to bounce back how
did you bounce back psychologically from
that loss yesterday why did you tell
yourself let's say at night
yesterday
i wasn't really psychologically in the
right place but
i still managed to
focus and play good chess
excellent so let's see that good chess
on display in today's game where did you
feel you had a strong advantage already
in today's game
even after bishop e7 in the opening
that's very early uh
yeah the bishop b7 already i feel it's a
little bit passive like he should try to
bring his bishop to b4 or c5
actually that is a very strange move
yeah bishop b7 is strange
because when you play d6 and the bishop
is kind of boxed out by the pawn
a curious decision and it seems like you
took full bishop g4 encouraging f3
what cannot be yeah i thought you were
going to play f3 on purpose yeah i i was
confused by this decision too
that is then you said thank you
yeah
a6 green three
and it just feels like black is getting
no space at all
in this game f45 is coming
yeah yeah this was a disaster for the
opening
this is how i play bullet on chess.com
with white right yes with white of
course
yeah this fell apart very quickly for
uh for him and
no recovery right it was king's still
stuck in the center no coordination this
is going to be a threat one day
yeah yeah this is just terrible
and this helps you out a little bit but
hey this is just completely hopeless
yeah yeah okay big game for you uh
christopher who do you have tomorrow in
the final round abi mishra oh
that's a big battle battle of the
teenagers how are you going to approach
that game just like any other game
trying to play good chess
well we're definitely looking forward to
that one that big clash thank you very
much uh christopher and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you
certainly a little bit of rivalry there
be between the youngsters still
it's hard not to compare them